parler de politique autrement c'est ce
que je vous propose avec mes capsules
web has not sur des enjeux politiques
québécois has not c'est le hashtag qu'on
utilise ici pour parler de ce qui se
passe à l'assemblée nationale nous avons
jusqu'ici tenté différents formats et
différentes approches mais toujours avec
un ton plus décontracté question de
pouvoir interpeller tout le monde dont
les gens de ma génération capsules web
j'en ai vu que la vidéo sur le web pose
un défi surtout quand il s'agit de
parler politique
en toute objectivité dans une mer de
vidéos drôles ou provoquant les ennemis
alors je veux vous entendre sur les
histoires politiques qui vous intéresse
et sur la façon dont vous souhaitez que
j'en parle suivi nous écrivez moi à
bientôt
[Musique]